the fastest way to accomplish any goal
that you have is to model success
find someone who's already done what
you're trying to do and put their
strategies to work for you
otherwise you're going to end up going
down the wrong path spending all your
time and money
on a route that doesn't serve you
when i had my first business it was hard
it took us a lot longer than we thought
it would take to get things going it was
a lot harder than we thought it was
gonna be
i was pulling out three hundred dollars
a month
three hundred dollars a month was not
enough
i had to tell my friends that i couldn't
go have dinner or drinks with them after
work
and it was because i couldn't afford it
and i was too embarrassed and too
ashamed to tell them
hey guys i know you're making your 80
000 a year as investment bankers and i'm
supposed to be living the entrepreneur
dream you're supposed to be jealous of
me
and i can't afford the 20 bucks that
it's gonna take to go out and buy some
drinks or have some dinner with you
and i reached a point where i just had
enough
like you can only go on for so long
without seeing something change
and i either had to find a way to make
this business work
or i had to go do something else
and then a light bulb went off
and i realized i'm in the software
business
and i'm not the first guy to try to sell
software before
somebody has figured this out
i just need to copy what worked for them
and make it work for me
so i looked at companies like microsoft
and how they got started i don't care
how bill gates makes an extra million
dollars now
but how did he go from zero to one how
did he make that first million dollars
that's what i wanted to learn from
and microsoft did it through
partnerships find someone who's already
selling to your target market and find a
way to work together
so apply that to my business within a
month i had my first deal
and close another one and another one
and continue to seek out companies and
individuals who we could partner with
who could help us grow our business
and these guys pulled us into the light
they showed us things we didn't
understand they introduced us to people
who we didn't know they gave us
knowledge that we didn't have
without these guys
i might still be making a couple hundred
bucks a month or i might have had to
shut down that business they pulled us
through
they helped us grow our business and
they helped us sell our business
and it all came from modern success at
microsoft
and i'm grateful that i found that
strategy but also frustrated that i had
to reach that bottom
such a low before i could figure it out
and so i hope for you that you'll find a
lot sooner than i did
whatever challenge you're facing right
now whatever goal you have somebody has
already figured it out
find out who they are copy their
strategies apply to your business and
you will shortcut your path to success
i guarantee it do it today
good luck